[Musik]
israel regierungspartei wählt eine neue
spitze amtsinhaber netanjahu gilt als
favorit sein einziger gegenkandidat ist
der frühere minister sei asien erinnert
an tsunami-opfer 15 jahre nach der
katastrophe im indischen ozean gedenken
tausende der toten
gemischte gefühle in der wirtschaft
während die baubranche zuversichtlich
ins neue jahr blickt haben
maschinenbauer unter exportzöllen und
dem brett zu leiten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster herzlich willkommen bei
unseren nachrichtenüberblick am zweiten
weihnachtsfeiertag und heute gibt es
auch wieder sport mit norbert lehmann
einen schönen und haben doch von mir in
israel wählen heute 116000 liegt
mitglieder ihren neuen vorsitzenden
und sie haben erstmals seit langem eine
alternative denn premierminister
netanyahu der die rechtskonservative
regierungspartei seit jahrzehnten
dominiert wird von ex-minister gideon
saar herausgefordert zwar gelten dessen
chancen als begrenzt doch der premier
wird geschwächt
über die verfahrene situation im land
jetzt annafest raketenangriff aus gaza
gestern abend während einer
wahlkampfveranstaltung von benjamin
netanjahu nahe der grenze zum
gazastreifen
israels premier wird in sicherheit
gebracht und kehrt wenig später auf die
bühne zurück mit deutlichen worten die
hamas und der islamische dschihad wollen
nicht dass ich gewinne
sie wollen nicht dass wir gewinnen aber
trotz ihres widerstands gewinnen doch
auch in der eigenen partei steht israels
premier enorm unter druck
zum ersten mal seit 14 jahren ernsthafte
konkurrenz von gideon saar dem
selbsternannten retter der rechten
der ehemalige innenminister gilt es noch
konservativer als netanya ich glaube
daran dass wir etwas verändern können
einen neuen weg einschlagen können und
wie eine starke und stabile regierung
formen können bisher ist die bildung
einer regierung gescheitert auf weil
netanjahu der in israel am längsten
amtierende premierminister angeklagt ist
wegen betruges untreue und
bestechlichkeit genau dass die chance
von gideon saar erzielt auf die
rationalität der potenziellen liegt
wähler er sagt netanjahu als
vorsitzender wird die partei nicht an
der macht halten
netanjahu dagegen zielt auf die
emotionen seiner wähler
verstand oder emotionen es gilt zwar als
unwahrscheinlich dass netanjahu die
parteispitze verliert für gideon saar
aber geht es vor allem um gute
ergebnisse
um sich für eine ära nach netanjahu zu
positionieren
die sperre des online-lexikons wikipedia
in der türkei verstößt gegen die
meinungsfreiheit das hat das türkische
verfassungsgericht entschieden
als grund für die blockade hatten die
behörden angegeben wikipedia einträge
hätten fälschlicherweise die türkei als
unterstützer von terrororganisationen
eingestuft luxemburgs außenminister jean
asselborn fordert alle eu-staaten auf
unbegleitete minderjährige flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen
so wäre es für niemanden ein kraftakt
sagte er dem magazin spiegel
es geht dabei um rund 4.000
minderjährige aus überfüllten lagern in
griechenland die debatte wurde entfacht
als der deutsche grünen-vorsitzende
robert habeck forderte kinder und
jugendliche nach deutschland zu holen
in asien heute einen tag des erinnern
vor genau 15 jahren am zweiten
weihnachtsfeiertag 2004 brachte einen
tsunami tod und zerstörung
ein seebeben der stärke 9,1 hatte die
riesige flutwelle ausgelöst
sie raste über den indischen ozean und
prallte auf die küste mehr als 230.000
menschen kamen ums leben
die meisten todesopfer gab es in
indonesien sri lanka und indien
auch thailand wurde schwer getroffen
über die gedenkfeiern oliver flammen
regelmäßig kommt sony malibran mit ihrer
nichte zu der gedenkstätte in pankow
tausende kamen allein hier ums leben
auch ihre eltern ich habe noch immer
große angst ich würde lieber woanders
leben aber mein vater und meine mutter
sind hier gestorben also muss ich hier
bleiben auch angehörige von touristen
sind gekommen die hier ums leben kamen
als die meter hohen wellen über die
beliebten feriengebieten teil
hereinbrachen verena zach war damals
dort im urlaub an den moment als sie von
den wassermassen mitgerissen wurde
erinnert sie sich genau wachbach dunkel
kaum licht und irgendwann habe ich auch
gemerkt ich kam die luft auch nicht mehr
länger anhalten ist presste sich alles
in mir zusammen
verena zach und ihr mann überleben für
zehntausende können die helfer nichts
mehr tun
noch viel mehr tote gab es in indonesien
auch dort trauern die menschen heute um
ihre angehörigen
wir kommen immer hierher zu diesen
massengräbern
denn wir wissen nicht wo unsere familie
begraben liegt ihre wunden sind noch
lange nicht verheilt auch 15 jahre nach
der katastrophe
wir schauen nach österreich und in die
schweiz wo es etliche lawinenabgänge gab
in andermatt in der schweiz verschüttete
die lawine mehrere skifahrer auf einer
markierten piste mindestens sechs
menschen wurden verletzt zwei von ihnen
kamen ins krankenhaus in der region gilt
weiter erhebliche lawinengefahr
die wirtschaft in deutschland kommt wohl
auch im nächsten jahr nicht richtig in
schwung
vor allem industriebetriebe blicken
weiter mit sorge in die zukunft
optimistisch sind laut einer umfrage des
instituts der deutschen wirtschaft die
bauwirtschaft und einige dienstleister
frank buchwald über die verschiedenen
branchen und wie sie ihre lage
einschätzen
christoph barre ist tief verwurzelt in
der region seine brauerei
familienbetrieb seit 1842 behauptet sich
in einem markt der immer mehr von
weltkonzernen bestimmt wird barre setzt
deshalb auf tradition und investiert
zugleich neue produkte etwa alkoholfreie
fassbrause
investitionen sind sehr wichtig in der
branche wenn man da den anschluss
verliert wird es ganz eng und wir haben
eine langfristige planung und auch im
nächsten jahr wird wieder investiert
viele unternehmen aber warten ab das
institut der deutschen wirtschaft hat in
48 verbänden nachgefragt nur 13 melden
mehr investitionen 21 branchen halten
das vorjahresniveau 14-fachen
investitionen zurück entwarnung für die
konjunktur kann nicht gegeben werden
auch wenn es ein paar lichtblicke gibt
zum beispiel auf dem arbeitsmarkt zwölf
branchen wollen neue leute einstellen
22 halten ihre mitarbeiter nur 14 bauen
ab alarmstimmung herrscht also nicht
manche branchen aber erleben einen
tiefgreifenden strukturwandel etwa die
autoindustrie elektromobilität gefährdet
viele arbeitsplätze maschinenbauer
leiden unter exportzöllen und alle
stöhnen über den brics it wir haben ein
interesse daran europa zu stabilisieren
aber wir sollten vor allen dingen auch
mehr klarheit und weniger schwankungen
weniger er artig in der klimapolitik
haben die ziele sind ja vereinbart wir
sollten sie nicht alle naslang noch
verändern
es muss der weg beschrieben werden dann
findet die anpassung auf stadt
zuversicht herrscht nach wie vor der
baubranche
auch wenn schleppende
genehmigungsverfahren und zu wenig
bauland dem wachstum grenzen setzen
im tarifkonflikt mit der lufthansa plant
die flugbegleitergewerkschaft ufo noch
vor dem jahreswechsel weitere streiks
schlichtungsversuche über weihnachten
seien erfolglos geblieben
die gewerkschaft will morgen abend
mitteilen wann genau gestreikt wird
vor 20 jahren am 26
dezember 1999 raste der orkan lothar von
frankreich kommend über deutschland
hinweg mit bis zu 200 kilometern pro
stunde richtet der sturm besonders im
südwesten enorme schäden an
neun menschen sterben bei donaueschingen
entgleist einzug in einem waldstück am
schwersten verwüsteten den schwarzwald
zahllose umgeknickte bäume breite
schneisen wie ist denn bald heute geht
zeigt antonia nie
bilder der verwüstung millionen bäume
wie holzstäbchen geknickt im
nordschwarzwald bei freudenstadt fegte
sturm lothar fast alles weg
millionenschäden für die weltwirtschaft
heute 20 jahre später ist ein neuer wald
entstanden und man weiß lothar hat der
forstwirtschaft neue chancen gegeben
natürlich zunächst mal eine
riesenkatastrophe wir hatten tote
verletzte riesige vermögensschäden
aber lothar und die wiederbewaldung der
großen sturm flächen hat auch dazu
beigetragen dass die naturnahe
waldwirtschaft bei uns einen deutlichen
schritt nach vorne gemacht hat
naturnah heißt auch keine fichten
monokulturen mehr mischwälder
das hauptproblem damals vor allem
fichten mit flachen wurzeln konnten dem
wind nicht widerstehen und vielen die
streichhölzer an der
schwarzwaldhochstraße hat man damals ein
naturdenkmal geschaffen
am lotharpfad hat man den wald ganz sich
selbst überlassen nichts wurde
aufgeräumt ein experiment des
naturschutzes
wir haben hier gesehen dass ich die
bilder wieder sehr gut selbst
regeneriert haben
es hat keine 20 jahre gedauert da stehen
jetzt wieder komplett jung wälder ohne
dass wir menschen dazu was bei tragen
mussten
der schwarzwald hat sich seit sturm
lothar verändert viele sagen zum
positiven
aber wie stark der neue wald wirklich
ist wird sich wohl erst bei einem neuen
organ zeigen
er war einer der wichtigsten tenöre des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
jetzt ist peter schreyer nach langer
krankheit in dresden gestorben
jahrzehntelang war er zu hause auf den
großen opernbühnen der welt wurde
international ausgezeichnet
[Musik]
nach seiner karriere als sänger
arbeitete schreier weiter ist dirigent
ein tag ohne musik ist ein verlorener
tag hat mir mal gesagt peter schreier
wurde 84 jahre alt
ja und nun zum sport norbert zu viel und
zum boxing day in england aber mit boxen
hat das kleingewerbe boxing ist das
englische wort für einpacken
früher da schnitten reicher am zweiten
weihnachtstag pakete für bedienstete und
bedürftige heute schnüren die fußballer
ihre schuhe dann rollt in der premier
league traditionell der ball die
spitzenbegegnung am abend lässt dagegen
liverpool und bereits am mittag besiegte
tottenham breiten mit 22 10 uhr -
fünfter sieg im siebten premier league
spieler ist tottenham trainer ein
kraftakt denn der tabellendreizehnte
ausbreiten spielt in der ersten halbzeit
mutig nach vorne
freistoß des ex ingolstädter pascal groß
und letzter mit dem 1 0 für die gäste
erst nach der pause wird tottenham
seiner favoritenrolle gerecht auch bei
brighton mithilft kane nutzt den fehler
zum ausgleich in der 53 minute in der
schlussphase erweist sich die
einwechslung von ericsson als
goldrichtig dessen exzellentes zu
spielleiter die beste aktion der
begegnung und zugleich den 2
1-siegtreffer für die spurs ein
die bereits übermorgen schon wieder
gefordert sind und bei uns in
deutschland gab es auch beim sport
nämlich handball
am letzten spieltag des jahres traf
unter anderem der bergische hc auf einen
der titelanwärter auf die rhein neckar
löwen und unterlag mit 26 29
beide teams hatten nach zuletzt
schwachen leistungen heute etwas
gutzumachen
insbesondere die gäste in den gelben
trikots hatten als titelanwärter zu
viele punkte gelassen hälfte eins konter
nationalspieler uwe gensheimer per
siebenmeter zum 16 12 für die rhein
neckar löwen abschließen nach der pause
jedoch kam der bergische hc nach diesem
sehenswerten treffer den darin nach
zuspiel von babak erzielt noch einmal
bis auf ein tor heran doch letztlich
wurden die löwen ihrem anspruch als
favoriten gerecht und gewannen das match
hier mit ihrem letzten treffer durch
laufen am ende ungefährdet mit 29 26
nun ist winterpause und im januar folgt
die em
das was von mir danke dir das jahr geht
zu ende
zeit zurückzublicken großbritannien auf
der suche nach guten ordnung im brekzie
chaos die welt hält den atem an als das
herz von paris in flammen steht ein
junges mädchen macht den freitag zum
streiktag deutschland im handball fieber
und bei der großen feier von 30 jahren
mauerfall die bilder eines jahres im
album 2009 10 gleich nach uns im zdf
ja das wetter soll von norden her wieder
freundlicher werden zu den einzelheiten
hören sie gleich gunther tiersch so viel
von uns wir sagen danke für ihr
interesse und wünschen vom gesamten
heute team noch einen schönen ausklang
des weihnachtsfestes morgen freut sich
dann aber häufig auf sie machen sie es
gut
[Musik]
einige zuschauer weihnachten geht zu
ende und das wetter wird langsam wieder
trockener der luftdruck steigt ja bei
uns ein hochdruckgebiet von skandinavien
legt sich nach norddeutschland darin
ließ die luft ein bisschen trockener und
kühler und die feuchte regen luft muss
hier zum mittelmeer über die alpen
ausweichen das tut sie heute nacht sie
streift uns nämlich im südwesten wird es
anfangen zu regnen an den alpen kann
sogar schneien bis auf 800 meter runter
innerhalb der nacht sonst ist es eben
neblig oder klar und im osten kann es
auch mal leichten frost geben im westen
bleibt es noch frostfrei morgen
vormittag lichten sich die wolken genau
deutschland weiter vor allen dingen im
nordwesten und westen aber im süden
bleibt es noch dicht anfangs vom
saarland bis zu den alpen noch regen
nachmittags dann ändert sich das nur
noch an den alpen südlich der donau
sonst würde es auch von norden her
trockener und die wolken von der ostsee
werden auch wieder dichter bei diesem
schwachen nordostwind die temperaturen
erreichen dann im osten nur noch werte
von 2 bis 4 grad am rhein im westen 7
bis 9 grad
es wird dann noch ein bisschen kühler in
den nächsten tagen aber sie sehen selbst
viel sonnenschein dabei selten mal
dichte wolken ich wünschen noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie es gut